Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir wollen sprechen über die internationalen Top-Ligen im Männerfußball. Wir begrüßen euch zur Ligatur hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass, Nummer 232. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ihr hört hier die Ligatur, ihr hört den Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Ihr hört jetzt gerade noch Max Jakob Ost, den Edgenetzer, auf Twitter und ich begrüße hier bei mir eine schöne Runde. Zum einen Nils Kern von Real total und natürlich dem Tiki Taka Fußball Podcast zur Spanischen La Liga. Hallo Nils, schön, dass du hier bist. Alles prima. Ich freue mich jetzt auf die Sendung mit euch und begrüße ebenfalls hier Alexis Menuge, der einzige ohne eigenen Podcast hier in der Runde, wenn ich das gerade richtig sehe. Alexis, wo bleibt der League 1 Podcast von dir? Hallo.
Was hat sich denn da verändert bei Arsenal? Oder sind gewisse Puzzleteile jetzt endlich mal zusammengefallen?
Also was man wirklich sieht, ist, dass die Mannschaft eine Mannschaft ist. Das sieht man sofort. Die jubeln zusammen, da pusht der eine den anderen. Gabriel, der Innenverteidiger, der mit einer Faust nochmal in die Fans so rein. Nach 60 Minuten so quasi, hey, gib noch mal alles. Dann Zinchenko wird ausgewechselt, der geht aber nicht raus. Sondern er schaut noch mal in die Mannschaft rein, so aufs Feld. Und sagt noch mal, hey, reißt euch zusammen. Das selbe macht Gabriel und Jesus. Gerade die beiden natürlich, mit City sind es gewinnen gewohnt gewesen, sollen, was man so hört, die Mentalität in der Mannschaft komplett verändert haben. Weil die einfach sagen, hey, wir hören jetzt nicht auf. Und das ist jetzt nicht nur alles lustig, sondern wir arbeiten auch. Und das ist natürlich der große Punkt. Trotzdem, wir haben ganz gute Quellen, was Arsenal betrifft. Der Verein war vor diesem Spiel schon sehr angespannt. Weil sie haben natürlich die ersten Spiele richtig gut gemacht und haben richtig gut gespielt und alles okay und sind da ganz oben. Aber die eine Niederlage war gegen Manchester United, die zu dem Zeitpunkt alles andere als gefestigt waren. Und Arsenal hieß ja eigentlich über allem schwebt. Und trotzdem haben sie dieses Spiel nicht gewonnen, sondern sie haben es verloren. Und dann war natürlich schon so die Frage, jetzt kommt wieder so ein großer, was ist denn, wenn wir dieses Spiel auch wieder verlieren? Denn dann ist dieser Status von, das ist gerade die heißeste Mannschaft der Liga und die können vielleicht sogar Champions League spielen, ziemlich schnell weg. Und davor hatten die schon Respekt und auch ein bisschen Angst im Verein. Die haben ein paar Sachen gemacht, wo man schon gemerkt hat, okay, die sind ein bisschen angespannt. Und dann ist halt genau der Punkt, der dann im Endeffekt wirklich für mich der Entscheidende war. Schaffen die es trotz dieser Anspannung, trotz diesem Druck noch, London Derby, alle werden darüber reden, alle werden über den Verlierer reden, halbes Jahr lang. Dass sie es trotzdem gestanden haben, muss man sagen, ist beeindruckend.
Und was haben sie da gemacht, was eben ein Anzeichen dafür ist, dass sie so ein bisschen unter Druck standen?
Da muss ich jetzt aufpassen, weil das nicht wirklich ein Interner ist. Und dann könntest du rausfinden, wer es ist und wer mir das gesagt haben könnte.
Aber es geht quasi um interne Abläufe. Hat man beim Training was anders gemacht?
War man in der Kommunikation nach außen anders? Es dürften ein paar Leute ein paar Sachen nicht machen, die ihnen eigentlich zugesagt waren. Mediale Auftritte, das habe ich ganz verklausuliert. Aber es wurde eher zurückgehalten in der Kommunikation nach außen. Hey, wir gehen jetzt nicht nach außen vor so einem Spiel. Wir bleiben jetzt eher in uns. Wir brauchen jetzt keine Publicity, sondern wir brauchen jetzt Arbeit.
Wenn ich mir die bisherigen Gegner von Arsenal angucke, dann sehe ich da Crystal Palace, Leicester City, Bournemouth, Fulham, Villa, dann eben die Niederlage gegen United, Brentford und jetzt dieses Spiel gegen Tottenham. Da kann man schon sagen, mit United in Klammern und vor allem Tottenham erst ein richtiges Top-Team mit dabei. Jetzt kommen allerdings die großen Brocken. Heimspiel gegen Liverpool, Heimspiel gegen City. Das wird alles jetzt noch im Oktober stattfinden. Du musst dich jetzt quasi festlegen, bevor wir diese Spiele gesehen haben. Danach werden wir natürlich schlauer sein. Aber hat es denn, Arsene, deiner Meinung nach, im Petto, dass man da mithalten kann?
Das würde ich schon sagen. Die Frage ist natürlich, ist ja auch ein Thema. Liverpool, so wie die momentan spielen, hat man es absolut im Petto. Weil, was glaube ich, haben sie auf jeden Fall. Auf der Höhe sind sie momentan mindestens. Sogar drüber. Citys mit Sicherheit dann. Absolut Benchmark. Das ist klar, weil, so wie die jetzt rollen, werden wir auch gleich noch draufkommen, mit wem die auch rollen, das musst du alles erstmal verteidigen. Und das glaube ich, ist auf jeden Fall die Benchmark, an der sich alles orientieren wird. Aber man muss eine Sache sagen, wenn wir uns natürlich hinstellen und sagen, das ist ja Wahnsinn. Die sind jetzt so und so, nach so und so vielen Spieltagen auf Rang 1, müssen die Meister werden. Ich glaube, das ist übertrieben. Aber zu sagen Champions League, klingt natürlich dann erstmal so quasi, naja, Champions League, ok. Aber für das, wo Arsenal herkommt, wo die eigentlich die letzten Jahre über waren, wäre das wirklich bahnbrechend einfach sagen zu können, sie haben ohne Probleme sich für die Champions League qualifiziert. Und das wäre ein Erfolg, wenn natürlich dann die Meisterschaft am Ende rausspringen würde, weil die anderen beiden oder drei oder vier nicht wollen, dann ist da mit Sicherheit keiner beleidigt. Und vielleicht gibt es so ein Momentum in dieser Mannschaft, dass die sich entwickelt und einfach so sich zusammenfindet und auf dieser Welle reitet, dass sie es doch irgendwie schaffen. Aber also, wenn es Champions League am Ende wird, glaube ich, ist keiner beleidigt.
Ja, das glaube ich. Also das, was ich so wahrgenommen habe bei Arsenal-Fans, die ich kenne, ist eher so ein Augenreiben. Und jetzt vor allem eben nach diesem Wochenende, dass man jetzt auch gegen die Spurs gewonnen hat in diesem so wichtigen Spiel. Aber wenn wir gerade bei Wellen sind, die geritten werden, dann müssen wir dann doch jetzt noch mal über Manchester City und Erling Haaland sprechen. Obwohl er schon im letzten Ligatur-Kurzpass-Kurz-Thema war. Damals hatte er zehn Tore in sechs Spielen, jetzt sind es glaube ich 14 in acht. Es gab ein unglaubliches Manchester-Derby am Wochenende.
Ja, also der Spieler ist wirklich unglaublich. Wir haben ja schon ein paar Vergleiche gezogen, wie Adriano bei Pro Evolution Stock Cup in Real Life. Gab es ja schon irgendwie den Vergleich. Ich habe ja gestern im Podcast bei uns gesagt, dass es eigentlich so wirkt, als würde immer, wenn der Ball zu ihm kommen, der Schwierigkeitsgrad des Spiels nach unten gestellt werden. Und alle anderen sind einen Schritt langsamer. Es ist einfach mega beeindruckend, was er spielt. Trotzdem, ich habe eine ganz nette Zahl zugeschickt bekommen. Man muss sich mal überlegen, der hat einen Expected Goals Wert. Das finde ich richtig spannend. 14 Tore. Und raten mal, was ein Expected Goals Wert ist.
Na ja, wenn du es jetzt so sagst, wird er wahrscheinlich sogar höher sein. Wahrscheinlich 15.
Nee, der ist bei 8,6 oder so.
Ach so, ach krass.
Das ist komplett verrückt. Aber, und jetzt ist natürlich der Punkt, das haben wir gestern mit Uli auch darüber diskutiert. Die Frage ist natürlich, warum ist das so? Der kriegt halt einfach auch wirklich Bälle serviert von anderen Spielern dieses Jahr. Also ich glaube nicht, dass der in Dortmund das Katastrophal schlechter gewesen wäre. Aber der kriegt natürlich, der hat natürlich eine Bräune, der einen Dinger auflegt, der hat einen Foden, der einen Dinger auflegt. Dann hat City natürlich dieses Konstrukt, das natürlich so erdrückend ist für einen Gegner, dass die einen allein schon mal 70% Ballbesitz haben. Und dann passt das natürlich perfekt. Er lauert immer um diese Drafraum-Ecke, um diese Viererkette-Ecke rum oder Dreierkette, was auch immer, und läuft dann im richtigen Moment ein. Und dann kriegt er halt den Ball auch zugespielt von diesen Spielern. Die Räume sind da, und dann macht er die halt. Der ist natürlich wirklich beeindruckend, aber Citys Spiel ist natürlich auch perfekt auf ihn zugeschnitten. Und das passt halt einfach nur. Das ist nicht so, dass die sagen, wir achten jetzt auf den so sehr, sondern er macht einfach genau das, was die Mittelfeldspieler brauchen. Und die Mittelfeldspieler machen genau das, was er braucht. Das passt einfach perfekt. Und dann kann der halt so was machen. Ist auch krass, die Zahl hat Uli rausgesucht. Er stand zweimal im Upside bis jetzt. Und der Typ macht eigentlich nichts anderes, als Tiefe anzugreifen. Das ist einfach ein beeindruckender Fußballer, muss man klar sagen. Trotzdem, die eine Szene, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das das dritte Tor ist. Der Bräune kann einfach vier Manchester-Spieler stehen lassen, als wäre es nichts. Und spielt dann den Ball in die Tiefe und er haut ihn rein. Manchester United war an dem Tag auch gerade in der ersten Hälfte wirklich einfach nicht auf dem Level.
Ja, das wäre jetzt auch so ein bisschen meine Frage gewesen, ob das vielleicht so der unbeachtete Nebenaspekt dieser Haarland-Manie ist, dass dadurch, dass sich alles so auf ihn konzentriert, vielleicht auch der Raum für andere offen wird. Ich meine, es gab ja noch jemand anderen, der einen Dreierpack gemacht hat mit vier Frauen in diesem Manchester-Derby. Das ist ja vielleicht auch ein ganz guter Hinweis darauf. Kann es eben sein, dass er es auch seinen Mitspielern leichter macht, weil er eben nicht nur dieser Zielspieler ist, sondern sich auch mindestens ein Verteidiger eher zwei wirklich auf ihn konzentrieren müssen? Und die werden ja dann auch gepinnt, also taktisch gesehen jetzt. Wenn er immer an der Abseitskante steht, dann sind es schon mal zwei Spieler, einer definitiv eher, wahrscheinlich sogar zwei, die sich nicht trauen, rauszurücken, wenn jemand anderes, wie zum Beispiel ein De Bruyne, wie zum Beispiel ein Grealish, wie zum Beispiel ein Silver, antribbelt und über den Zwischenraum reinkommt.
Ja genau, und das ist ja ein sehr interessanter Punkt. Wenn du dir mal den Masterplan City-Angriff vorstellst, dann ist es ja meistens irgendwie, dass sie versuchen, in diese, man nennt das glaube ich, Strafraumtaschen zu kommen. Also da so ungefähr ans tiefe Fünfer-Eck, so ungefähr. Und da dann quasi, also sich irgendwie durchzukombinieren, mit einem Doppelpass vielleicht dahin zu kommen. Und dann ja eigentlich zurück auf den Elfer, zwischen Elfer und der Fünfer-Linie, dort den Ball reinzuspielen, damit der Stürmer nur noch reinschieben kann. So hat die Aguero quasi 90% an die Tore geschossen bei City. Weil es ja eigentlich immer dieselbe war, versuchen im Dreieck da rauszuspielen, dann ist man an der Grundlinie, legt den Ball nochmal zurück und der schiebt ihn nur noch rein. Das war ja eigentlich immer das. Und wenn man dann aber überlegt, dass ja eigentlich die letzten Jahre über kein Mittelstürmer da war, und sie schwierig hatten, sich dort reinzukombinieren, oder selbst wenn sie es getan haben, dann war halt keiner da, der irgendwie ablegen konnte. Jetzt ist es so, es konzentriert sich, wie du sagst, mehrere Leute auf Haarland. Du kannst dich leichter da rein kombinieren. In dem Moment, wo du da bist, denkt sich die ganze Abwehr, oh mein Gott, wir müssen da jetzt wieder hin. Wir müssen da wieder zumachen. Und in dem Moment ist der Haarland wieder frei. Also das hat alles so Domino-Effekte in diesem ganzen Spiel. Dass halt immer irgendwo einer frei ist, weil sich halt immer mehrere Leute auf Haarland konzentrieren müssen. Ein paar müssen sich dann auf die Bäume konzentrieren. Dann ist der Foden plötzlich völlig frei. Dann denkst du dir, warte mal kurz, jetzt müssen wir den Foden mal zustellen. Er hat schon zwei Tore, dann ist der Haarland wieder frei. Die haben einfach so eine unfassbare Qualität davor, dass man einfach wirklich sagen muss, das ist einfach beeindruckend und fast schon Tütenmode irgendwie.
Aber würdest du sagen, dass sich da jetzt noch mal irgendwas verändert hat, jenseits der Person Erling Haarland? Das ist halt jetzt auch eine gute Geschichte. Deswegen erzählen wir die alle so gerne. Wenn man da jetzt noch mal im Detail drauf gucken würde, dann könnte ich schon ehrlich gesagt eine ähnliche Argumentation fahren, wie mit Arsenal, dass man sagen könnte, naja, Manchester war jetzt vielleicht auch der erste, in Anführungszeichen, richtige Gegner auf Augenhöhe. Ich will es nicht kleinreden, aber wir sind ja auch, wir fallen ja auch immer gerne auf so Narrative rein, weil sie auch so schön sind. Hat sich denn auch was verändert bei Manchester City? Spielen die jetzt auf einem anderen Niveau? Oder ist es halt das sehr hohe Niveau der Vorsaison ergänzt um jemanden, der halt extrem gut im Torabschluss ist?
Muss man auch sagen. Mein 3-3 gegen Newcastle, da hat er einmal getroffen. Dieses 4-0 gegen Bournemouth, das habe ich zum Beispiel kommentiert, da war er ja mehr oder minder abgemeldet. Da hat er kaum wirklich stattgefunden. Also natürlich, wenn die mal rollen und er einfach abschließen kann, dann ist das mit, ja, man kann nicht reden, was der für eine Qualität hat. Aber ich will das dann schon mal sehen, wie es dann in diesen großen Spielen ist, aber dann die Chancen eben auch bekommt. Wenn es dann vielleicht mal enger wird, wenn vielleicht mal cleverer gegen ihn verteidigt wird und vielleicht auch das Tempo beim Gegner ein bisschen höher ist. Da bin ich schon gespannt, wie es dann aussieht. Weil wir haben es ja, also zum Beispiel, man muss ja schon sagen, sie haben Sterling verloren. Ich finde, dass das schon ein Spieler ist, der wichtig ist. Das ist schon ein guter Spieler. Sie haben Sincenco verloren, sie haben Gabriel Jesus verloren. Der Kader ist, finde ich, jetzt nicht mehr ganz so breit. Calvin Phillips, der Neuzugang, ist quasi immer verletzt. Also der Kader ist nicht mehr ganz so breit. Sie haben keinen wirklichen Linksverteidiger in dieser Saison. Sie haben schon auch ein paar Fragezeichen. Das interessiert natürlich jetzt keinen Menschen. Wenn die so spielen und so hoch gewinnen, dann gibt es niemanden, der Fragen stellt. Da bist du wahrscheinlich der Einzige. Aber es wird so weit kommen, dass auch über City diskutiert wird, bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Wahrscheinlich würde er mir genau das Gegenteil beweisen, aber 14 Tore in 8 Spielen, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass er auf diesem Niveau weitermachen kann, weil irgendwann wird es auch jemanden geben, der ihn stoppt. Und dann bin ich gespannt, was City als Alternativen hat. Wenn er dann eben raus ist, wenn sich dann vielleicht schon viel auf ihn eingespielt hat, dass sie eigentlich immer ihn suchen, er vielleicht aber nicht mehr gefunden werden kann, erzählt dir dann Plan B, ist natürlich viel what-if, aber kann natürlich theoretisch schon sein. Das weißt du besser als ich sogar, wie oft er verletzt war. Lass ihn mal irgendwas haben und der ist ein halbes Jahr raus, was machen sie dann? Dann ist ihm auch ein Sterling weg zum Beispiel, dann hast du natürlich schon wieder ein weniger und kriegst du es dann noch hin, so viel Torgefahr auszustrahlen mit Bernardo Silva, mit Jack Grealish? Das ist dann die Frage.
Ja, wir werden es beobachten. Noch ist City ungeschlagen in der Liga und auf Rang 2 mit 20 Punkten nach 8 Spielen und wir haben einen Trainerwechsel, also einen weiteren Trainerwechsel in der Premier League gesehen. Das ist noch unser kurzes, letztes Thema. Was ist in Wolverhampton los?
Bruno Lars ist entlastet worden nach dem 9. Spieltag. Das haben schon viele vermutet. Es war nicht katastrophal, wie sie gespielt haben. Es war auch nicht katastrophal, was die Ergebnisse betrifft. Aber ich muss einfach so, was wir gehört haben, atmosphärische Störungen gegeben haben. Er ist der Nachfolger von Nuno de Santo. Er sollte ein wenig offensiver spielen, ein wenig attraktiver spielen. Das ist nicht wirklich gelungen, muss man klar sagen. Sie haben gerade mal 3 Tore nach diesen 8 gespielten Spielen, die sie gemacht haben. Das ist einfach viel zu wenig. Sie haben sehr schwache Expected Goals-Werte. Sie spielen sich sehr wenig raus. Sie erzielen auch sehr wenig Tore. Defensiv ist es okay. Neun Gegentore ist so la la. Aber sie sind offensiv so harmlos. Das hat mit Attraktivität auch gar nichts zu tun. Dann, was man hört, muss er mit den Spielern individuell gar nicht gesprochen haben. Wenn, dann war er sehr emotional und sehr aufbrausend. Und teilweise kolärisch, fußballerisch. Ich glaube, taktisch kann man ihm nichts vorwerfen. Das ist mit Sicherheit jemand, der eine Idee hat, der den Kader noch mal umgewälzt hat, der versucht hat, das aufzubessern, was Bruno Espírito Santo verpasst hat. Nämlich, sie wollten eigentlich einen breiteren Kader, einen tieferen Kader. Sie wollten weg von der Dreierkette hin zur Viererkette. Mit schnellen Außenspielern, mit schnelleren Innenverteidiger. Haben dann den Kapitän, Conor Cody, gehen lassen, weil er meinte, der ist A, zu langsam. B, er kann nicht Viererkette spielen. Jetzt spielt aber in Everton genau das. Er spielt Viererkette und es funktioniert. Und bei Wolver Hilton funktioniert es überhaupt nicht. Und was passiert? Er geht am Ende wieder auf die Dreierkette zurück gegen West Ham und spielt dann mit Ruben Neff zum Beispiel hinten drinnen einem zentralen Mittelfeldspieler, einem der besten der Liga. Und sagt zudem, du bist jetzt der zentrale Mann in der Dreierkette. Das sind natürlich so Dinge, die passen hinten und vorne nicht zusammen, muss man ganz klar sagen. Denn er wollte ja die ganze Zeit einen Stürmer haben. Dann hat er ihn am Ende bekommen mit Kaleicic. Der hat sich verletzt. Dann musste er mit Dio Costa nochmal nachbessern. Dann sah es so aus, als wäre der Kader verhältnismäßig breit geworden. Weil man ja z.B. mit Mateusz Nunez, noch ein Spieler verpflichtet, in der Mitte fällt. Dann lässt man Gibson White gehen, dann lässt man Den Donker gehen. Dann ist man am Ende des Tages wieder so weit, dass der Kader eigentlich total dünn ist wieder. Genau da, wo sie eigentlich weg wollten. Das sind alles so Punkte. Irgendwie hat alles nicht mehr zusammengepasst. Ich glaube, er war über die Kaderpolitik auch nicht unbedingt begeistert. Und natürlich dann diese Probleme in der Offensive, dass sie einfach gar keine Gefahr ausgestrahlt haben. Hinten aber auch nicht mehr stabil genug waren. Und dann muss man halt irgendwann mal sagen, okay, wenn es dann auch menschlich nicht mehr passt, dann glaube ich, muss man sich trennen. Schade, weil jetzt glaube ich irgendwie schon, ich fand ihn jetzt nicht unsympathisch, aber die Wolverhampton war mal, wenn du dir überlegst, als die aufgestiegen sind, die haben Geld investiert, die waren so the next big thing, sind zweimal Siebter geworden. Dann dachten alle, jetzt marschieren die in die Champions League. Das stand auch in jeder Saisonvorschau damals. Und was ist passiert? Das war dann nämlich auch zwölfter, vierzehter. Also das ist halt das große Problem. Da hat ein Verein eine riesengroße Chance liegen gelassen. Alle haben sich ein wenig zurückgenommen. Es wurde ein bisschen weniger investiert, ein bisschen weniger progressiv und so weiter. Und jetzt ist man halt wieder da, wo man eigentlich vor dieser Investitionsphase aus China war. Nämlich man ist einfach wieder langweiliges Mittelmarsch, sogar eher etwas drunter. Und jetzt ist es eigentlich wünschenswert, dass es irgendjemand wird, der vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Strahlkraft hat. Amorim wird zum Beispiel schon genannt. Sergio Contessao wird genannt. Aber das wird dich jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht überraschen, dass der Pass portugiesisch sein wird.
Ich habe mich schon gefragt, was Trainerkarussell auf portugiesisch heißt.
Genau, ich weiß es auch nicht, aber wir werden es mit Sicherheit rausfinden. Ich kann es daneben bei mal googeln. Aber das ist genau das, was im Endeffekt so momentan kolportiert wird, dass es eben wieder in Portugiese wird. Aber das darf jetzt auch nicht großartig verwundern.
Das überrascht nicht. Also, wo wir hinten aktuell auf Tabellenplatz 18 mit 6 Punkten dahinter, konnte jetzt Leicester zum ersten Mal gewinnen gegen das Schlusslicht Nottingham. Die beiden haben jetzt 4 Punkte. Also inzwischen hat jetzt jedes Team der Premier League einmal gewonnen. Und alle anderen Themen müssen wir dann in der nächsten Ligatur besprechen. Jogi, ich danke dir sehr für deine Zeit. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war unsere nächste Rasenfunk Kurzpass Ligatur. Gebt uns gerne Feedback, wie euch die Folge gefallen hat, unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de oder im sozialen Netzwerk eurer Wahl. Wir sind auf allen Wegen zu erreichen, außer Fax. Ansonsten habt eine gute Zeit, bleibt gesund. Es geht hier weiter im Rasenfunk nach dem nächsten Spieltag der Männer-Bundesliga. Kommt die nächste Folge bis dahin. Bleibt gesund, macht es gut und bleibt uns treu. Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk.